il y a plusieurs dizaines de tués il y a
beaucoup de blessés
c'est une horreur
vendredi 13 novembre 2015 il est 23
heures 53 quand françois hollande le
visage grave prend la parole à la
télévision
la france vient de subir les pires
attaques terroristes de son histoire
tu es j'étais entouré tout commence en
début de soirée à saint denis en plein
match de football entre la france et
l'allemagne
à quelques minutes d'intervalle trois
kamikazes se font exploser aux abords du
stade de france et confus en fait ce que
l'on a entendu deux explosions bon
départ je pensais que c'est les bombes
agricoles
après il ya plein de rumeurs à
l'intérieur du stade une victime est à
déplorer
au même moment des bars et restaurants
de la capitale sont les cibles d'un
commando armé
trois hommes et mitraillent les
terrasses bondées des blessés étendus
sur le sol
des cris et des passants qui s'affolent
d'abord le carillon puis le petit
cambodge deux établissements du 10e
arrondissement
viennent ensuite les terrasses de la
casa nostra de la belle équipe et du
comptoir voltaire dans le 11e il y avait
beaucoup de soutiens tous les
commerçants sont sortis
le traiteur d'à côté essayait de donner
des perfusions mais c'était une vraie
une vraie scène de guerre le bilan est
lourd 39 morts et de nombreux blessés
il attaque la plus meurtrière c'est
celle du bataclan le soir du 13 novembre
mille cinq cents personnes assistaient à
un concert à 21h40
trois terroristes armés pénètrent dans
la salle tirs en rafale avant de prendre
en otage le public
j'ai entendu un gala hurler à la wac
barre deux fois de suite
et puis tout le monde s'est effondré je
me suis fait écraser par toute la foule
qui tombaient comme des dominos après de
longues minutes d'attentes leur aide et
labeyrie donnent l'assaut l'intervention
dure cinq minutes des trois terroristes
sont tués là aussi le nombre de morts
est élevé 90 au total nous sommes à
quelques dizaines de mètres du bataclan
un poste de secours vient d'être
improvisée dans un restaurant les
pompiers tentent de réanimer les
spectateurs les plus gravement atteints
au lendemain des attaques
les parisiens sont sous le choc certains
n'ont aucune nouvelle de leurs proches à
l'image de cette femme très émue moi
j'ai pas de nouvelles de mes copines qui
sont passés les soirées d'or et la c
beaucoup d'émotion
ce 13 novembre 2015 cent trente
personnes sont mortes sous les tirs des
terroristes
[Musique]